[Music]
what kind of stuff do you tease your dad
for so many things and it's warranted
yeah he's a weird guy he's he's a lovely
guy but he's starting to do things and
I've told him to his face so I don't I
don't feel terrible saying it in this
private setting right he is doing stuff
that I affectionately him like that is
baddy old man stuff right he's he does
not harm them he's catching squirrels
the dad's catching squirrels and he told
me this and I was like I don't want to
hear this that's that's I cook you're
officially a crazy old man he's like
it's fine my friends doing it with me
and like that's okay Warren's doing it
wait a minute Lorenz what are they doing
when they catch holes he catches
squirrels in his backyard dad and he
catches them in like a like a little box
with mesh yeah because he's always like
they're ripping up the roof like they're
not ripping through your roof is fine
these case convinced they're ripping up
his roof right which I do join them in
his car yeah and he transports them to a
park I mean it's better than when I
first heard it I thought he was taking
him to the basement like there's no
there are no taxidermied squirrels
anyway right he does he very gently
takes them to a park but he's there
surrounded by trees I'm like you're not
gonna get rid of the squirrels dad so he
has a whole thing and he won't stop
doing it so I just keep kind of now
acquiring like squirrel paraphernalia
what and sending it to him no you got
some stuff your cuz he's gonna come out
you're gonna you want to redecorate for
him is that right I'm doing I'm
renovating a house and there's a room
that you know it's gonna be like a guest
room for the grandparents and I just I
kind of can't help myself every time I
find something with scooch he doesn't
know this hopefully maybe I should make
him not watch this
I found the squirrel wallpaper you found
spoiled it's actually really pretty put
their squirrels all over it and then I
found he's squirrel sconces
but they look like feral squirrels there
it's a little jarring they look like
feral squirrels that have like crawled
up and then they're and they're holding
it's like a squirrel I brought a picture
I think you buy these look at that your
pork I'm gonna put all over their room
and just wait till my dad was like now
wait a Minu he's gonna do he's going to
wake up in the morning being like gonna
drive him to a park like if they attack
him in his car I'm like you deserve it
yeah yeah yes I don't want to hurt yet I
want him charred and rattle you want his
car filled with crazed squirrels that
are alive attacking him and him earring
down Main Street hey no harm to come to
anyone but I wouldn't mind giving him a
good scare with those school you
shouldn't be trapping squirrels and
transporting them no I don't know he
knows what he's doing trust me I'm sure
your dad's very qualified to be doing
this he's great at help squirrel family
I was like what if they have children
yeah why did daddy go to the bathroom I
wrote everything battering acorns
you